all right we have this uh dog coming on
tonight i'm sorry i
i'm sorry to interrupt you okay uh i
want to point out somebody special
in the audience tonight um i'm sure you
all remember
i'm sure you remember it's my little
sister stacy oh there she is
sure i remember her yeah hey
hey there hey there stacy
oh boy stacy you look uh all ready for
st patrick's day next tuesday
yeah i am
[Laughter]
you know this is real really cute
because
i mean you know our family we're not
even irish but uh
she's pretending to be an irish because
she's got a big crush on you still
got that thanks a lot annie you're like
totally embarrassing me
come on stacy it's cute that you're
trying to be irish for conan
andy i am irish
top of the morning to you guys
sure and viggora and um
sodom and gomorrah
she's she's really been going all out
[Music]
actually liz could you show you some of
those photos that i brought uh
first one this is a cake that she baked
for you
st patrick's day that's sweet and then
here she is uh
she's pretending she's performing for
you and river dance oh
it's a river dance thing and cut out and
finally here she is in disguise
she's gonna buy us some guinness
that's so sweet they didn't let her
thanks a lot annie now kona thinks i'm
like the leprechaun of loserville no
no i don't stacy i think you're a sweet
pretty young lady
you do well sure i do and i'm really
flattered that you
pretended to be irish for me
you really mean that sure i do
i sure do and you know what i'm sure
there's lots of young men who'd just
love to spend st patrick's day with you
what about you
well that's that's really sweet stacy
but uh we're doing a show that
night and then after that there's a
there's a party at my girlfriend's house
no no don't feel bad for me
what'd you say just uh just a few
friends it's gonna be like a little
get-together
just a good like good get together yeah
that sounds good sounds really cute
sweet you and your girlfriend
basking in the glow of holiday revelry
while i lay wounded and weeping
consumed by the fires of a hell that you
made
say stacy i'm i'm really sorry stacy
don't get upset
you shut your pie hole big brother
or i'll tear you apart like a chevy at a
chop shop
oh my god
that's gonna hurt too yeah you listen
orion
let me tell you something just like the
irish cast away their shackles of
british oppression
i too will cast away my shackles of love
chains that have bound me in misery
to your bony white ass
listen stacy just please forgive me no
nay never freckle boy
the time of redemption is at hand
and as the long banshee wails
in the cold distant forest
i will see your pale celtic flesh
hung torn and tattered
on the red walls of my vengeance
i i i i and andy i i i don't i don't
know what to do
i think i do
wait a minute who are you hi i'm raymond
i go to stacy's junior high school
i don't remember you i'm sick a lot
anyway the point is well hey we're the
same age
and well i sure would like to spend
st patrick's day with you if you want to
that is
okay you know what raymond that's really
nice
but um i don't know you and i don't
think we have anything in common
no we do we do we do have something in
common
i have a crush on conan too
[Applause]
all right we're gonna take a break folks
i my apologies we'll be right back with
bill the runaway dog stacy no
you